[Music]
Brody Jenner is set to tie the knot any
day now with his longtime fiancee
Caitlyn Carter in Bali but one person
who won't be in attendance for their I
Do's the 34 year olds dad Caitlyn Jenner
a source tells ET the 68 year olds will
not attend her son's wedding due to
previously scheduled work commitments
but adds that everything is good between
them in fact according to the source the
former Olympian is throwing a party for
Brody and Kaitlynn when they return to
Los Angeles following their wedding and
while Caitlyn may not be there for her
son's big day she did celebrate her
future daughter-in-law in April
attending her bridal shower at the Santa
Anita Park Racetrack in Los Angeles
alongside Brody's mom Linda Thompson
Caitlyn shared this shot of her with a
29 year old writing went to my first
bridal shower for a Brody's fiance
Caitlyn Carter I had so much fun
PS so much better than bachelor parties
Carter commented on the post quote I'm
so happy you were there it meant a lot
to me
[Music]
[Applause]